Jake Paul actually recently told UT he
still wants to avenge his brother and
take you on I'm gonna knock him out in
the first round yeah yeah and I still
want to you know come up so it's
definitely going to happen
JJ man how are you holding up in
quarantine yeah no I'm good I'm good
like if anything I'm wrong it's like
nothing's really happened yeah obviously
because I'm a youtuber I'm able to just
post YouTube videos indoors and you're
do I do normally
yeah and just just go and moving forward
obviously you know the album coming out
everything's going 100 miles an hour so
yeah I'm trying to adjust yeah well I've
got my feel around see me when I'm on my
donkey night everything
as first of all congrats on the new
album I want to talk about like the
process of making it though what point
did you finish it and you know at what
point did the features happen too
because I was wondering to myself
looking at this list by the way all the
feature artists on there it's stacked
I'm like did any of those happen while
you're in foreign team um
well quite quite a few actually
so we've requested little baby that was
before the whole boxing with upset that
was I believe that was in we're working
like December January
um yeah he did his thing in LA I was in
England at the time and then I also went
to LA to record what was your reaction
when you heard his track for the first
time all insane and say I like like his
verse is ridiculous filled out but she
killed it and uh and it just goes so
well into the chorus and everything yeah
it's uh that's a big guy and I'm excited
to listen to it yeah for sure it's a
yeah it's a big song Jeremiah
yeah again this was during so this is
when coronavirus died becoming a thing
and start to get in the way so I wasn't
able to travel to LA to record but uh
you know he did his thing and we made it
work and then yeah you know I record a
lot of songs in my flat I've got a
studio literally opposite this room and
allows me to just you know you've been
doing music before you too but I feel
like this is your baby like I know this
has been a huge passion project what do
you hope fans learn about you through
this record like are we gonna get to
know JJ a little bit more versus ksi
yeah I feel like people are gonna know
more about I guess my personal side of
things um you know obviously I'm a
public person and a lot of people know a
lot about me but you know there's
everything's I keep you know close to my
chest and I don't really you know put
out publicly but I feel like
doing a few music is therapeutic
especially with certain things I talk
about you know there's other songs where
I talk about you know my significant
other etc so you know I I'm a lot more
you know I just show a lot more my
personal side which a lot of people
hardly ever see you're more open to time
yeah most of time into chaos on I'm sick
I'm the best blah blah blah they swallow
that but yeah yeah it's gonna see
another side to me which well how would
you say que si the artist is different
than your online or you to persona you
know I just I guess there's a bit I do
use a bit both so with the braggadocious
appalled me i definitely implement that
in my music i scary sign but uh you know
i guess i'm a lot more serious when it
comes to music yeah it's just a
difference then it's kind of like box
there's no time to laugh or joke it's
you know it's a serious thing I'm going
to war so you know you have to be in
that right mindset and I kind of bring
down this to this I bring that with
music as well do you feel like you're
going to war with this particular record
though you know do you feel any pressure
to really I don't know stake your place
in the music industry yeah you know I
could say you could say that for sure I
never feel like I have to work harder
than the traditional musician because
I've come from you cheapen obviously
people are gonna say are the only reason
people are listening to you because you
have a larger audience but you know
that's not my fault
it's it's just because you know I'm
doing so many different things we've
used music with the YouTube box thing
you know opens me up to a wider audience
so obviously they're gonna be interested
in everything that I do but uh you know
this is I guess me showing people and
the world that I can do music and I can
excel in it it's clear you totally like
shifted your focus to music especially
right now obviously you're just a couple
of days away from you dropping the album
but like as you point out people are so
if
your every move no matter what a lot
because of YouTube I know that I mean
things are still hung up on that Logan
qualifying you said you're over it so in
that sense though do you feel sometimes
being attached to something like that or
even YouTube distracts from your music
or do you feel like it's hell
oh no I I feel like for me I know when
to just you know like split it right
down the middle and move on like yeah
yeah I'm able to just switch like switch
it just like that when I'm like okay I
need me Nietzsche boat I'll switch it to
YouTube mode what I need me importa mode
I'll switch to the boat summer the same
of music like yeah have to be able to
just you know cut off everything else
and just focus on what you focus on else
you know it gets muddled up and then I
don't feel like I used my way of it you
know is there any future plan to jump in
the ring I know that Jay Paul actually
recently told et he still wants to
avenge his brother and take you on sides
who beat your brother right yeah exactly
Wow and now I'm gonna beat him I'm gonna
knock him out in the first round
yeah yeah and I still want to you know
come on so yeah yeah it's definitely
going to happen I don't know when but
you know Oh to arena England yeah it's
going down for sure soon you're gonna
run out of Paul Brothers like oh yeah I
feel like after I destroy him YouTube
box it's done I mean yeah don't really I
don't really see you know who else I
could fight then it's kind of like I've
completed it right now yeah Jake's the
person in my line of sight yeah well
speaking of YouTube did you see
PewDiePie he actually praised your music
career I think what case I was doing
recently when musics inspiring he's
doing good
I like seeing it with the video today I
I saw it yes I was really cool like I
have so much respect for beautify we've
you know we've had our differences over
the years but you know there's always
been that respect you know a hundred
million subscribers that's no easy cost
and he is literally the only youtuber to
do it so that's insane and you've got
get props them I love that so there is
no beef you guys are cool down
now you have it I mean yeah I mean I'm
pretty sure with what chill right we
just were just in different parts of the
internet you know like he does his thing
I do my thing but you know we respect
each other's I respect that cuz
obviously you are competitive right by
nature but do you feel like there's room
and space for everyone no matter what
whether whether it's youtuber music Oh
100% like you know we live in the age of
the Internet where there's so much room
for opportunity it's on it's unreal and
you know right now is the perfect
example of that like right now you know
we can't go out and do what we normally
do so we have to adapt and you know
people are seeing this as an opportunity
to do better and do more in their lives
[Music]